guys using high explosives in a chaotic
firefight can be difficult look whether
you call it nitro cells or c4 there's no
denying it's one of the best tools in a
defenders arsenal and while using it can
sometimes go horribly wrong it's still a
great way to get highlight real kills on
unsuspecting enemies defuser
we'll get sexy for throwing out and
which is why this week on top ten we're
counting down the 10 best nitro cell c4
plays in professional rainbow 6 siege
it's hard to stay calm and collected
when you're in a 1v1 clutch situation
especially when you're staring down
match point but that's exactly what me P
did in our opening play with excellent
map knowledge and weapon usage VP keeps
his cool and throws a perfect c4 to deny
the plant and keep his team's hopes
alive so this is where the Intel's gonna
be fed and he is gonna get tight and
meet me essentially should be able to
win this drawing fight he's actually
gonna Tegel up first and potentially
transfer to c4 as I will get tossed like
does he my [ __ ] 8 does maybe gets the
coach y from maybe we talk about is Kim
sense that just shows how smart this guy
is you probably don't want to be killing
teammates with your C fours or yourself
for that matter but as our number 9 play
shows sometimes things just work out and
you win the round anyway here at lunar
metal shows us that no sacrifice is too
great in order to secure the W the Mira
shotgun comes out
to get that one to it now winning the
sepal killing in luna mental and odin
missiles wow what a way to go to us oh
my goodness
sometimes if you see it well then it's
already too late which is exactly what
happened in our number eight play as
life Zord accepted his fate dying
alongside his teammate with a well toss
a nitro cell from cameraman Blackbeard
is down and only a Spectre what a toss
from cameraman he takes hugs or ten life
sword the two sword combo this moment
they knew
ah it's beautiful at number seven is one
of the most calculated nitro cells
you'll ever see mark is gonna miss it
anyway okay so maybe it wasn't on
purpose but mark does show us that c4
can act as a well-placed trap and catch
a rushing enemy off guard with sieges
destructible environment players have
the freedom to get creative and our
number six play has to be one of the
craziest setups we've ever seen here
phases ma'am tosses his nitro self from
the Attic through the south wall and
down the floor for a cheeky kill on some
poor soul in classroom fees they're
gonna hit a wall c4 will get psycho
well tossed but still no rotation
potential and because of that Astro
stuck will get eliminated by wag but wag
refract by MAV MAV having an amazing
round really doing a great job upstairs
ma'am yet another kill kamikaze Goes
Down and there's only one attacker left
but MAV was that an eighth number five
on our list takes place on a tide map of
a tide series during a grand final
fabian refuse to let EG take the lead
and pull through with a clutch nitrous
el on canadian
the ash drops to the ground along with
the diffuser and with no time left on
the clock baby and hides from the
remaining player stealing the round from
eg in heartbreaking fashion is this
before from Fabian he primes at canadian
falls off he goes down young will be to
get in he has only ten seconds and he
enters they will be in a standoff can he
get the Valkyrie two seconds young
pushes up running out of time
never count DC out when he has a nitro
cell in his pocket coming in at the
number four spot we have eg on the verge
of elimination Fabian was looking to
plant the defuser but found himself on
the receiving end this time around as B
C's nitro cell takes him out it's gonna
be up to BC to collection yet again the
mirror playing inside a small office
he'll go for a c4 tosses it out go ahead
BC have to live for two seconds continue
fight him evil geniusness will stick the
third round BC another clutch oh my word
did not expect that to happen that's for
sure our numbers think play C's rogue
able to plant the defuser under the
cover of glass and a smoke grenade with
a3 b2 advantage rogue look good to take
the round but were not expecting the c-4
to come from nvk and it looks like
emojis and Kate is yeah they will
beautifully play there by an Kane and a
great nitro by a VK
Oh GA rainbows ex fit series out at the
runner-up spot we have Rafael who lands
four kills with a nitro cell from below
and to top it all off finishes the round
with an ace laser though I find it soon
burrito 1v4 you've just run out of
bullets you've got a sliver of Health
one plastic explosive in a dream oh yeah
and you're playing kapkan for eske's
Nick's in our number1 spot he turned
that dream into reality as he loved a
Hail Mary nitro cell down the hatch into
the server room ending the round with a
swift bang Dotson watch 1v5 ace but the
next captain how does that happen well
guys that's all I got for you on top 10
this week now if you do want to see more
rainbow 6 siege content like the video
subscribe to the channel and let me know
in the comments so we can make it happen
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button